après avoir échoué sur les masques et
sur la stratégie des tests le
gouvernement de jean castex ne veut pas
trébucher une troisième fois avec la
campagne de vaccination qui s'annonce
pour cela le premier ministre s'est
voulu pédagogue et rassurant face au
risque de défiance généralisée à l'égard
du vaccin contre le coc vite 19 je
souhaite que les français aient accès à
toute l'information dont nous disposons
nous mêmes c'est pourquoi notre
stratégie vaccinale sera présenté au
parlement dans le cadre d'un débat prévu
par l'article 51 de la constitution au
cours de ce mois
je m'engage à ce que durant toute la
campagne la vaccination tout la
transparente toute la pédagogie soit
faite sur les décisions que nous
prendrons et sur l'organisation que nous
mettrons en place une campagne de
vaccination qui se déroulera en trois
phases
dès janvier les personnes âgées vivant
en établissement médico social notamment
les ehpad et les personnels à risque de
ces structures seront vaccinés en
priorité
la phase deux concernera les 14 millions
de français présentant un facteur de
risque liée à l'âge ou à une pathologie
chronique et commencera dès le mois de
février
enfin le reste de la population devrait
pouvoir se faire vacciner au printemps
l'objectif est clair vacciner
massivement la france disposera ainsi
d'un potentiel de 200 millions de doses
ce qui permettrait de vacciner 100
millions de personnes puisque le vaccin
nécessite à ce jour deux injections à
quelques semaines d'intervalle c'est
plus que nos besoins
la vaccination sera gratuite pour tous
et le gouvernement a budgété à cette fin
1,5 milliard d'euros dans le budget de
la sécurité sociale pour 2021 un plan
qui ne convainc pas une partie de
l'opposition jean castex interrogé pour
savoir si lui se fera vacciner bafouille
hésite visiblement embarrassé fini par
dire sans le dire clairement que non en
tout cas pas maintenant on imagine qu'il
attendra de voir ce que ça donne la
défiance envers les vaccins est
extrêmement élevé la confiance ne se
décrète
être pas elle se construit comment avoir
confiance quand l'ex lobbystes deux
géants pharmaceutiques
monsieur viossat a été choisie pour
organiser la stratégie vaccinale contre
le coc vide 19
un scepticisme qui ne toucherait pas que
certains opposants selon un récent
sondage près de 61% des français
seraient réticents à se faire vacciner
contre le corona virus un véritable mur
de défiance contre lequel le
gouvernement va tenter de ne pas
s'écraser